hi everyone two images were released
first a look at Tom Hardy as Eddie Brock
in the upcoming venom movie so
truthfully from the comet to Tom Hardy
Marty arrived at set one day and some in
turn took a photo of them but also
there's a set photo of the cake and the
Avengers infinity war a wrap party guys
there's even more to these than meet the
eyes we can laugh but let's pull our
obsessive new rock stars lens out here
okay first let's look back at this
picture of Tom Hardy now on the surface
this photo seems yes kind of lame just a
shot of Tom Hardy in street clothes
laying some bracelets or two cool what
exactly as I imagined Eddie Brock play
by Tom Hardy - right right
he's got his reporter's notebook but hey
those notes say something we can either
zoom or enhance say when you zoom you
lose resolution it's so dumb but we love
it okay well hit enhance
I'm explaining the joke this is classic
era coverage okay
staple of the show if you look closely
you can see the life foundation written
down in his notebook so just explain the
life foundation is from the Marvel
spider-man comics they're a society of
elites who believe that the world would
be destroyed a nuclear holocaust and
they took various dark measures to
survive it and plan for their utopian
society thereafter now in the venom
lethal protector series they kidnapped
venom in extracted five symbiote
children from his DNA to create soldiers
to protect their new society those
included scream phage riot Lasher and
agony now Benham and spider-man had to
end up teaming up together to defeat
them all we'll see how this affects with
the news that carnage would be the
villain of this movie maybe they're like
retconning carnage is origin to have the
light foundation behind his attachment
no no well they could definitely still
do off from his symbiote right we
could have a lot more valence it could
be carne engine and those are people who
lead his way to uncovering how carnage
is another symbol don't add more bones
yeah well also those five like I know
there's fans out there of those five but
it's fine if they don't it's fine right
on papa
there's also toxin there's also
anti-venom there's like I'm it's a
million more that you can do those five
are fine for not being in a movie for
the next like couple years venom three
we'll get those and we'll be everyone be
happy about it yeah but that makes sense
for carnage like honestly off the top of
my head I can't remember I all I know is
that carnage was Venom's like they the
symbiote made a little baby and it went
to Cletus Kasady because they shared a
cell and that's what it is and then they
they joined and they made right they
found him in prison and that's yeah and
this you could just take Cletus or
whatever character you want to play
carnage I you guys can calm down it's
okay if it's not clean it's gonna be
somebody I know well part of me was just
like they might change name Cletus is
just a slack-jawed yokel yeah and like
it's trying to be changed and also it
makes sense like you get a prisoner you
want to test out if we can take the
symbiote and give it to somebody else
and like no you can't like it doesn't
work that way and like carnage is goes
crazy and starts killing a lot of people
yeah III could see just the light
foundation being used as like part of
his conspiracy that he's uh that he's
like under uncovering to find out like
how far his symbiote has traveled and
he's found out of this like secret
society has been actually using this
sickness that he has in his soul to
weaponize it and do horrible things with
it so he's that's how what leads him
into the story that's my guess of why
they're pulling the life foundation as
like a detail from the comics I also
heard that they were gonna pull from the
the planet the plant venom planet
stories but with the Clint are like what
they are and everything they'll be kind
of interesting to really complicated
when you get into that like it's new I
mean that thing is pretty obvious that
this picture tell give us all the
answers can we do a cake down now yeah
okay let's move on a second images him
enhance on yesterday the rooster
brothers who directed the two upcoming
Avengers movies
tweeted a picture of this epic
take for the wrap party now that
production on both movies has ended now
just look at this when does this stop
being a cake and start being art that is
probably edible is all art edible I
brought you a paint you know okay but if
you look closely some of the design
features may include some details for
the upcoming films
I can't believe we're analyzing it well
these are these are people that have
been exposed to these shoots at least
Infinity Ward they definitely know a lot
more than we do they'll be referencing
some inside jokes about how the plot
will go or some of this art that they've
had to construct on set server you're
saying there's a get a cake there's
gonna be a cake in the movie is that we
were saying or this cake is the entire
plot of the film that's what I'm it's
written on the app we don't need to we
just got a look at the cake the new rock
stars theory approach okay look at this
it depicts Thanos falling back as he
collects his Infinity stones he's
holding the blue space stone in one hand
the green time stone in the other at his
feet as a red reality stone on the
surface beneath him is a yellow mine
stone in the purple Power Stone and then
at the bottom corn if you look closely
the edge of the cake is the orange soul
stone which we still have yet to see in
the MCU probably gonna be in black
panther we'll see um now along the
middle tier are the logos for the
Avengers characters there's Hulk cap
Iron Man Thor and Black Widow presumably
the logos of the other MCU heroes line
the other side to the cake or maybe
everyone else will die and those the
only and then from that tier this is
probably most interesting you can make
out 3 arms bursting out of this cosmic
field to grab the platform that the
Annis is standing on the one closest to
us is Black Widow the the wrists mo
there is a signature of hers but the
other two are a bit harder to tell
there's a reddish one behind hers I'm
thinking it might be vision I would say
strange but he wears the yellow gloves
Oh vision you're right I was thinking
Iron Man but there's no there like it
was never do it and then the one in the
back has claws that are scraping the
surface making me think it's black
panther's vibranium claws the one in the
very very back you can't even see the
army to see the claws that are scraping
gotcha okay now someone suggested that
these three are the ones who might die
but guys I highly
Black Panther Black Widow will die in
these Avengers movie sounds like Marvel
has big plans for both of their futures
although vision mmm I could see him
going down we honestly I think that they
might be twisting things because
everyone can see vision dying especially
what the stoners so I'm thinking like
also these could be the ones that make
it right these are the three to survive
or the three to like bring the this trio
teams up in some interesting way to go
on some mission to destabilize maybe
that's like a metaphor we can look into
I don't know what do you guys see any
clues on this cake that might tell us
what about the other arm I only see
three do you see a fourth yeah oh you
guys see the arms and then that one's
bursting out at the bottom looks like
crystals or something that one going up
it doesn't look like so much like an arm
no the left that yeah I don't think a
pillar but just because it's bursting
out like the rest of them it seems more
important I figure to tell I think it's
purposes for cake physics okay but
you're right they probably wouldn't have
just done that and not decorated that
one part and they left it at yellow cake
that's not like it was just like with
the lighting of the thing like we
couldn't really tell what it is but
maybe you guys are right it's probably
maybe it's dr. Strange's cloth it could
be something like that oh yeah if we're
not like yeah you got a good idea that
this could be just a false lead Oh or
maybe the cake designer just wanted to
do those forearms on the sledge on the
spatula someone got into this cake love
the detail in Dennis's face and pecs and
the pecs and the pecs that they have
there did you guys see them they're very
defined do you think you can eat Fantas
no yeah unless you hold the entire
gauntlet holding the umbrella over the
cake in the picture like where was it I
thought wasn't a studio because they
have those blue screens set up this is
why would they ever bring this cake out
in the rain so yeah those blue screens
are interesting those are the ones that
they actually bring to when they shoot
out in the real world you bring those
screens up and you block out certain
things and now you can relocate anything
it happens all the time on show
like law and order and this shows like
name so they don't Ragan's flying around
and shoot in the middle of the day
whatever thing she's really wanting to
add people later yeah that's pretty cool
I'm surprised that they've said they
wrapped both films already which is very
impressive I know this could be reshoots
for the next couple months a year four
years I think in April or May when the
movie comes out I'm definitely going to
want to go back and look at this cake so
be good I think yeah no it's this cake
stays good for everybody what is that
intern driving it to the set was
probably having a heart attack because
that's how do you move that how do you
get that anywhere comment down below or
hit us up on Twitter at new rock stars
with your thoughts thanks guys thank you